so hi everyone my name is Max I work at
github on the atom text editor team and
I want to tell you today about a project
called tree sitter that I've been
working on for about four years now to
try to improve on some of the core
features of text editors so tree sitters
started out as a as a hobby project for
me before I even started working at
github but now it's it's part of a
couple of products that we were making a
github and so I'm gonna tell you today
explain what tree sitter is and talk
about how it's different from some other
things you might have used and then I'll
show you some of the things that we're
building at github with tree sitter and
then finally I'll talk about how tree
sitter works and some of the algorithms
that it uses so first what is tree
sitter tree sitter is a library for
parsing source code it's written in C
and C++ and it's designed to be used in
applications like atom that work with
code written in many different languages
so you can use tree sitter to parse
files written in all different languages
and produce syntax trees that all have
the same interface but the really unique
thing the tree sitter does is what's
called incremental parsing and that
means that once you've parsed the file
with tree sitter you can then edit the
file and tree sitter can give you a new
syntax tree that reflects the edit that
you did without having to reparse the
whole file over again and creating that
new tree is super fast and it uses very
little memory because the new tree
shares parts of the old tree that
haven't changed from when you edited so
this feature makes it possible to use
tree sitter to do to parse source code
in a text editor like atom on every
keystroke while the users typing and to
use the syntax trees on multiple threads
at the same time an application without
worrying about race conditions and the
other interesting thing that tree sitter
does is what's called error recovery and
so that means that you can give tree
sitter code that is invalid either
because you're in the middle of typing
the code or because the code uses some
non-standard language features that the
parser doesn't know about
and if you do that then rather than just
aborting and giving you an error message
like all commonly used parts do tree
sitter has a way of inspecting your code
and figuring out where the start and the
end of every error is and giving you
back a useful syntax tree anyway so
that's a feature that makes it possible
to rely on syntax trees the true sitter
gives you even when you're parsing code
written by the end user which you might
not fully understand so that's tree
sitter what Theresa does and now I'll
talk about how it's different from some
other things that you may have used so
Tree Center was mostly inspired by some
IDE s that I've used like intellij and
webstorm and I really like ideas because
they they parse your code while you're
writing it and they use those parse
trees as the basis for all the features
in the IDE and so everything that I didi
does is really smart but the problem in
IDE s is that they're really tailored
toward a specific language and they're
pretty slow usually so none of the ideas
that I know of do the kind of
incremental parsing that I just talked
about and so that means that whenever
you type a character in an IDE the IDE
has to reparse your whole file from the
beginning which can take tens or
hundreds of milliseconds which is
actually a really long time when you're
talking about typing in a text editor
and you can see that delay sometimes in
an ID when you type something and
there's a delay before the syntax
highlighting updates and so another cool
alternative to IDE s as language servers
so with a language server you can just
use a regular text editor to actually
write your code and then you use a
separate language specific program to
analyze your code and to provide your
text editor with these standard features
like go-to definition and autocomplete
so language servers are a really cool
way to implement those particular
features in a text editor
but when you use a language server
there's still a lot of parts of your
text editor that are pretty dumb like
core features like syntax highlighting
and basic cursor movement and editing
are not enhanced
by the language server and so they don't
they're not aware of the structure of
your code and another thing about
language servers is they pretty much
have the same performance as I des
they'll get your laptop fan spinning
really loud because most of the time
they have to reparse your file every
time you you type a character and
there's also a little bit of overhead to
having to send data back and forth
between the text editor and the language
server and so the language servers
really work best for features that can
tolerate a little bit of latency also
language servers all have their own set
of dependencies usually associated with
the language that the server is built to
work with and so for applications like
atom and github comm that want to be
able to work with a lot of different
programming languages out of the box it
doesn't really make sense to bundle a
whole bunch of language servers into the
application because that would just add
a ton of complexity and so a lot of
these problems that the language servers
don't try to solve theresa to does solve
it it gives you back a syntax tree that
you can use to do whatever kind of code
analysis you want in your application
and it's extremely lightweight and fast
so we can embed it directly into the
text editor as a replacement for the
simple regex based systems that most
text editors come with for doing syntax
highlighting and also it has no
dependencies and it in fact it's written
in pure C and all the partials are pure
C's so it's easy to embed them into any
application no matter what language the
applications written in alright so now
I'll show you some of the things that
we're doing with procedure today at
github so first I'll show you what we've
done with syntax highlighting so I think
syntax highlighting is super important
because it's something that most of us
use pretty much all day every day while
we're working whether we're looking at
code in our editor or on a website like
github comm or stack overflow and most
of the time that you see syntax
highlighting today it usually looks a
little bit like this this is a
screenshot from sublime text 3 but it's
pretty similar to what you'd see in most
any text editor or code website
and what we're looking at is some C code
that defines a data type and some
functions and I just want to point out a
few major problems that I have with the
syntax highlighting so this code
contains a whole bunch of words and some
of those names refer to types and some
of them refer to variables and some of
them refer to fields of structures and
for me it would really help me to read
the code if all of the type names were
their own color but it's not that way at
all the types are actually four
different colors here char is purple and
un 32t is blue green and then the type
that we're defining is black first and
then yellow in another spot for some
reason and similarly if you look at all
the struct fields I would like them to
be their own color because they're
different from types and they're
different from variables but they're not
they're just black which is the same
color as much of other things and then
finally I would want local variables to
be their own color different from the
other things I just mentioned and I
would definitely want any given local
variable to always be the same color
anytime it appears but that's not the
case here either this variable that I'm
pointing to shows up first in yellow and
then in black and both of those colors
are also used for other things so like I
don't think this syntax I think is very
useful and this is pretty commonplace I
would say and the reason it is this way
is that tools like these use these
simple regex based systems to do syntax
highlighting that really just aren't
powerful enough to recognize the things
that need to be recognized if you want
to make code really readable and just to
show you that this isn't like a C code
specific problem I'll show you some
similar code written in C++ instead of C
and if you look at the types and look at
the field names and the variable names
you can see all the same problems and
the same thing happens with go code and
with rust code and with probably most
other languages as well and it's also
not just a problem with this particular
syntax
color scheme that I've chosen or with
this editor if you look at another
editor like vs code and you look at the
types here char un 32t node see the same
problems and the struct fields again are
not highlighted consistently and the
same thing happens on github.com where
we all like to read code and until
recently the same thing happened in adam
but let me show you what it looks like
now that i've reimplemented syntax
highlighting to use the syntax trees
that tree sitter gives you looks like
this so you can see that all the
problems that I called out are fixed now
the types are all blue green no matter
if there are some known list of types or
if they're user-defined type the struct
fields are all red both when they're
declared inside of the struct definition
and when they're used and the local
variables are all black so to me this is
like ideal syntax highlighting this is
what I always want code to look like and
it might seem like a subtle improvement
to you but I really think it it actually
achieves the goal of making it so that
you can kind of get the structure of the
code just from glancing at the colors
and so to help show that I'll again go
through the same code written in
different languages so you can kind of
see that there's the same pattern of
colors that you can recognize so here's
the C++ version and now here is the go
version where you can kind of tell that
the types have moved over to the right
instead of being on the left now and
here is the rest version and here's
typescript version so in all these
languages and a bunch more we've made
code a lot more readable and so another
good thing about computing syntax
highlighting this way based on the
syntax tree is the way that we can
handle long lines so if any of you have
ever opened up a a minified javascript
file in a text editor you might remember
that you you either get no syntax
highlighting or just a teeny little bit
at the beginning of the file and that's
because of the way that syntax
highlighting usually works is by running
a whole bunch of individual regex
searches
on each line and so the longer that the
lines get the longer this all these
regex searches take so now with tree
sitter that's not a problem anymore we
can we can compute syntax highlighting
super fast regardless of how a file is
broken up into lines and we can also do
a much better job with just the overall
speed of highlighting any file
particularly large files if you've ever
opened up a really large source code
file that more than a couple hundred
kilobytes in a text editor like vs code
or atom and then scroll down a bunch
after opening the file you remember that
it takes a while before the those later
lines of the file get colored because
the syntax highlighting systems are slow
and so on this slide I'm just showing
how long it takes to parse a really big
javascript file in this case the
development build of react with with
tree sitter and so the the file is like
twenty thousand lines long it's six
hundred something kilobytes and tree
sitter can parse it in like 54
milliseconds which is fast enough that
we can pretty much show you all the
colors
instantly when you open the file so now
I'll show you our Adam's new code
folding system so code folding it's
pretty simple lets you hide parts of
your code that you don't want to look at
right now and usually the way it works
is that is based on indentation so lines
that are indented further get hidden and
that oftentimes works but not always
so in a lot of languages it's common to
have functions written something like
this where the functions got several
parameters and each parameter appears on
its own line and so that the indentation
actually decreases when you get into the
body of the function and so this kind of
style like breaks present-day text
editors in a variety of ways in I think
sublime text just doesn't let you fold
functions if you write them this way and
vs code and previous versions of atom
would would allow you to fold the
function but it would look
weird because half of the parameter list
would get glob together with the
function body and so now with tree
sitter we can fold functions like this
just fine because we compute the
locations of folds based on the syntax
tree instead of based on the indentation
of the lines in fact you can even strip
away all the formatting from your code
and you can still fold it just fine
because we're doing it this way
we're just actually useful sometimes
because sometimes you you want to copy a
whole bunch of code from one place and
paste it into another in a way that
messes up the formatting at first and
you can use code folding to to kind of
get a sense of if the structure is
actually correct or not another thing
that I really like is that it's now
really easy to define your own commands
that fold your code however you want
based on the syntax tree like I have a
simple command in my in my atom config
file that just folds all the bodies of
functions and nothing else and it works
across all the languages that I use even
though they have wildly different ways
of writing functions in the different
languages and the code for it was super
simple and fun to write actually it's
just I just can query the syntax tree
kind of like if you've ever used
JavaScript on a web page to query the
Dom you can query the syntax tree like
that and I can find all the nodes in the
tree that are either functions or arrow
functions or method definitions and
what-have-you and for all those nodes I
can find the child node that represents
the body of the function and create a
fold there another cool one that my
coworker Ashe came up with is for
working with test files there's a common
style of test framework where you write
your tests using these functions
described and it and the describes can
be nested inside of each other so if all
the descriptions of your tests can be at
many different indentation levels in
your file and so ashe wrote a custom
folding command that just queries the
syntax tree to find all the functions
that are named the calls to functions
named it and to fold create folds there
so you can read your whole your whole
test file
so I think these I like these things
because they're they're pretty minor
conveniences but they showcase the power
of what it looks like to have a hackable
text editor where the syntax tree is
available at all times you can really
you can really customize your editor to
do whatever you want to your code so we
also added a new feature that I love to
add them called extend selection
inspired by some IDs that I that I like
so extend selection is a simple command
that when you run it it selects larger
and larger structural elements of your
code based on the syntax and so on a Mac
you type alt up to select up the syntax
tree and then alt down to go back down
from where you came and it's a super
simple concept but it's really
satisfying to me because it reinforces
this way of thinking about editing code
as you're editing a logical data
structure you're not just editing raw
text and it's also really practical like
in this example I use it with multiple
cursors to reformat this whole data
structure in a way that would actually
be really time-consuming to do if I had
to manually move the cursors around to
do it
so an extend selection not to go on too
long about extents selection but it it's
really changed the way that I refactor
my code too like I had this case where I
had a data structure that was a field
that I wanted to make private and so I
wanted to replace all of the places
where that field was used with a call to
a standalone function like a getter
function and this is something that like
even if you if you're a pretty advanced
code editor and you're really good at
reg X's and vim macros and all that
stuff you really can't do this in a
general way without without you know
manually looking at each case because of
all the different ways that the code can
be written but with extend selection you
you really can you just use multiple
cursors and you you go up the syntax
tree to grab each field expression and
then you kind of move your cursor to
take the left hand side and you wrap it
in a function call and you go back up
the syntax tree whoops
to get to the end of the function call
and then you can delete the field that
you were trying to get
so anyway makes editing a lot more fun
for me
so aside from github comm we're also
using Tresor sorry aside from Adam we're
also using tree sitter for some
experimental features on github.com so
this is a feature that shipped almost a
year ago now it's kind of been under the
radar some of you may have seen it where
if you're looking at a pull request and
you you open up the table of contents
now you can see underneath each file
that's changed the list of all the
functions that have changed or been
added or deleted and so this was built
by a separate team in github x' data
science org and they have are doing some
really cool work to analyze syntax trees
and diff syntax trees but they use tree
sitter for all of their initial parsing
because it gives them this uniform easy
way to parse a wide variety of
programming languages and so between the
work that I do on on the atom team and
the work that they're doing on
github.com we're kind of building up a
bigger and bigger set of languages that
you can that you can use tree sitter
with and so just yesterday we released a
new version of atom that that finally
enables tree sitter by default it's been
behind a feature flag and atom for
almost a year and so I'm hoping that now
that we've released that this the set of
languages that you can parse with tree
sitter is going to grow even faster
because now people who use atom will be
able to write their own parsers for for
languages that we don't support yet and
so the hope is that in the future you
can use this library to parse whatever
programming language you want so now
I'll talk about how tree sitter works so
when you want to add support for parsing
a new language with tree sitter you have
to write a context-free grammar that
describes the language and the grammar
is basically a list of all the
constructs in the language and then it
specifies how you write them in terms of
other constructs in the language and
with tree sitter you do that in this in
JavaScript using
some simple JavaScript functions that I
wrote and so the the grammar is just a
simple of JavaScript value and I did it
that way because it really makes it easy
to programmatically define parts of
grammars or the most interesting one is
to to define a grammar in terms of
another grammar so like I use this this
feature to define the C++ grammar in
terms of the C grammar and to define the
typescript grammar in terms of the
JavaScript grammar so once you've
written your grammar there's a
command-line tool that you run that the
reads your grammar and it spits out one
piece of C code that's your parser and
the C code has two main pieces to it
it's a standalone C file that you can
that you can compile by itself and it
the first part is a what's called the
lexer function so this is a big long
function that reads the input character
by character and groups the characters
into tokens the basic tokens of your
language and then the second main part
of the the parser is what's called the
parse table so this is a big
two-dimensional array that tells the
parser when it's in a given state and
when it sees a given token what kind of
actions it should do and when you go to
actually use these parsers the way you
do it is you use them in combination
with this one other library that's
called the tree sitter runtime that
defines the basic data types that the
tree sitter parser uses so there's a you
create a parser and then you set the
language on it and that's the language
is what is the code that's generated
from your grammar and then you can parse
code and get back a syntax tree and
inspect the nodes of the syntax tree and
the nodes have this simple uniform API
that's a little bit like the Dom they
just all have a type and they all have a
start position and an end position and a
few other properties to them so this is
showing the Rossi API which you probably
usually wouldn't use we have bindings to
a few different higher-level languages
there's a JavaScript binding
which is what we use in Adam and there's
a Haskell binding which is what the the
github data science team that I
mentioned earlier uses because they they
code in Haskell and it's also a rust
binding that I just created for fun so
that's what it kind of what it looks
like to use tree sitter and now I'll
talk about some of the algorithms that
it uses internally so most of them are
based on some research that was done at
UC Berkeley in the 1990s and in
particular this one PhD dissertation
called practical algorithms for
incremental software development
environments and that dissertation kind
of lays out a complete methodology for
doing really efficient code analysis in
an IDE or an editor and it talks about
what basic parsing theory you should
start with and then how to extend that
theory to deal with with incremental
parsing and then it formally proves that
the that incremental parsing algorithm
has these really good performance
properties and it also talks about how
you should handle ambiguities and errors
and a bunch of really useful topics and
so the basic parsing theory that it's
all based on is LR parsing so LR parsing
is like one of the classic parsing
theories that was invented in 65 by
Donald Knuth and it's the basis for a
lot of popular tools like yak and bison
some of you might have learned about LR
parsing in college if you took compilers
class I didn't actually I didn't take
computer science classes so I ended up
learning about LR parsing from this
Wikipedia article I have on the slide
it's really good Wikipedia article
really like lays out the whole thing and
talks about how you generate an LR
parser so I highly recommend that one so
so a lot of the more unique thing that
tree sitter does is built on LR parsing
so I'm going to briefly talk about just
how regular LR parsing works for a
second so the basic goal just like any
parsing is to take a sequence of
characters that has some implicit
structure to it and to produce a
that explicitly describes that structure
and so the way that an LR parser does
that is that it reads the characters
from beginning to end without ever
backing backtracking and as it reads
them it groups the characters together
into tokens using the lexer function a
lexer function like the one that I
showed you on that earlier slide that
was the first part of a generated C code
and those tokens it groups them together
into larger and larger sub trees which
it stores on a stack and every new token
that it finds it decides what to do with
its with the stack by consulting the
parse table and that that was the second
piece of generated C code that I showed
so I'll walk through just a basic
example of parsing a math expression
like x times y plus Z so the parser
would start out at the beginning of the
string in a some starting state with an
empty stack and it would run the lexer
function and find that the first token
in the string is a variable the X and so
then it would look in the parse table
for what to do with that variable and it
would find out that it needs to push it
onto its stack and it would do the same
thing for the next two tokens the star
and the y and then it would find the
plus token using the lexer function but
then when it when it looked for what to
do there in the parse table it would
find that it needs to do the other type
of action which is called a reduction so
that's where the parser pops some number
of sub trees off of its stack and then
groups them together into a new parent
sub tree and then pushes that back onto
the stack in their place so in this case
it would pop off the X star and the Y
group him into a product and push that
onto the stack and then the parser would
push the plus and the Z and then when it
reached the end of the file the parser
would again see that it needed to do a
reduction so it would pop off the the
products the plus and the variable and
group them into a sum sub tree and that
would end up being the root node of the
the final syntax tree that's the the
basic
and so you might have a question like
okay but so this the stated goal of this
library is to be able to parse any
programming language and so is is LR
parsing this one theory of parsing gonna
be able to work for all the languages
and so the answer to that is no not
quite almost because most programming
languages are designed to be pretty easy
to parse using some a few different
parsing theories that are actually less
powerful than LR parsing LR parsing can
kind of in a certain sense recognize all
a large set of grammars but a lot of
languages also have some weird quirk to
them that needs to be handled via just
ad hoc code in the compiler and so let
me give you an example of one of those
weird quirks true Souter has a few
different ways that it deals with the
weird quirks of languages but I'll show
you one of them so these are two pieces
of JavaScript code on this slide and in
the first one we're assigning to the
variable X the value of the variable Y
and we've wrapped Y in parentheses just
for no reason just because that is valid
to do in JavaScript but in the second
example we're assigning to the variable
X an arrow function that takes a
parameter called Y and returns another
value Z and so the reason that these
this kind of code would be a challenge
for a regular LR parser is that it has
to do with the syntax trees that we
would want to create for these two
examples so for the first example where
Y is of we're evaluating Y the way that
gets represented in the JavaScript
grammar is that there's a node called an
expression that means that something's
being evaluated and so the Y identifier
wants to be in wrapped in an expression
to indicate that we're evaluating it
whereas in the case of the arrow
function that's not what Y is Y is just
the name of a parameter and so it has
this different structure where it's just
an identifier node inside of a formal
parameters node and so the the again the
reason that this is a problem for
our parser is that like I said I know
our parser never backtracks
and so in this case before the LR parser
can move past the right parenthesis
after the Y it has to decide what should
be on its stack to represent the why
should there be an expression subtree on
its stack to represent that or just an
identifier so I'll show you the way that
the Crusader deals with this it's via an
extension to LR parsing called glr that
just stands for generalized LR parsing
and so I'm gonna walk through the
example of parsing the the second
example the arrow function and I'll show
you again some diagrams of the parsers
stack these ones are in a different
format because this is a format that's
actually generated by tree sitter to
help you debug parsing and in this in
this these diagrams the the names of the
sub trees are appearing over the lines
in the graph and what's in the bubble is
the the state number that the parser is
in so the parser would start out just
via the normal LR parsing it would push
on to its stack the first four tokens x
equals the parenthesis and a y
but then when it got to the right
parenthesis that's where the ambiguity
of the local ambiguity is and so what G
LR parsing says to do is to fork the
parse tack into two different branches
so that the parser can simultaneously
try both interpretations of the code
without backtracking and so we've got
the upper branch where the Y is just an
identifier so that's the case where
we're interpreting it as a parameter to
an arrow function and then in a lower
branch we've wrapped Y in an expression
so that's the case where we're we're
interpreting it as as if we're
evaluating Y and so we'd have to proceed
parsing on with the two branches for for
just two tokens until we see the arrow
and at that point we can realize that we
can chop off one of the branches because
an arrow wouldn't be valid after a
parenthesized expression and so then we
can continue on with regular LR parsing
so that's the basic approach that allows
tree sitter to be so general to parse
parse all these programming languages
like C++ typescript that contain a lot
of ambiguity
so another algorithm that I'll show you
is the way that tree sitter recovers
from syntax errors so like I mentioned
at the beginning we need one when
there's an error we want to return a
subtree or we want to return a tree
anyway and the tree just should include
nodes that indicate where the errors are
and so in this example you have an if
statement and someone just started
typing a for loop before the if
statement and so we have this invalid
state where it says for if parentheses
and so the tree that true sitter would
produce would have a complete if
statement in it and there would just be
this extra node that represents the fact
that the word for is not supposed to be
there and similarly if you actually did
have a for loop but then you
accidentally wrote the word if in the
middle of it tree sitter would produce a
different tree where it it parses it as
a for for loop and it has an error node
in the middle of it that says that the
word if is not supposed to be there so
in either case that can kind of tell
what the best interpretation is of what
you've done but the interesting thing
about these two cases is that they both
start out with the same sequence of
tokens so it's not as simple as as some
as like oh just do some fixed procedure
when you first encounter the error and
the way that I think about it is it's
very similar to the way that you need to
handle local ambiguities like the one I
just described a second ago with the
arrow function and the parenthesize
expression like you can't know how to
interpret the error until you look a
little bit further ahead
and so tree sitter uses the same
facility of G LR parsing for dealing
with syntax errors so when it sees an
error like the word if after the word
for I can force fork the parse tack into
a couple different branches in this case
to to try different means of recovering
from the error either to discard the the
word for or to discard the word if or
other things and so again we can
continue with multiple branches of the
parse tack for a while until we figure
out that what works best is to parse
this as a as an if statement and in this
other case to parse this as a for
statement so as far as I know this
technique is novel of like leveraging
the glr algorithm for dealing with
syntax errors but it works really well
in Adam allows us to really quickly give
back a good syntax tree even when you're
in the middle of typing something in
kind of the same way that the it has
that same virtu as the the crude reg X
based systems that the editors have
today where they kind of work even if
your your code isn't quite right so the
last algorithm that I'll show you is the
way the tree sitter does the incremental
parsing so once you have a syntax tree
when you do an edit how do we come up
with the new syntax tree really fast so
say you had this JavaScript code VAR a
equals new be a dot C return a I'm
showing the in small the the syntax tree
for that and now I'll show you what
would happen if you were to insert the
letter D here inside of the argument
list to add an argument to the function
and so what tree sitter the way tree
sitter would process that is it would
walk the current tree that it had and it
would mark all of the nodes in the tree
that contained that position the
position where you edit 'add as having
had one character inserted into them
so those are the green nodes that I show
in the diagram and then to create a new
tree tree sitter would would start in
the same initial state that it would
have started in as if it were just gonna
parse the whole file all over again
except that now it has this reference
which is the old tree and so it can
reuse nodes of the old tree that haven't
changed and that which were created in
the same par state that the parser is
currently in so that's the case in this
example that's the case for the whole
first statement so the the variable
declaration can be reused in its
entirety and so can the the first part
of the second statement namely the the
member expression a dot C and even the
left parenthesis right before the Edit
can be reused and then once once you
reach the site of the edit tree sitter
has two parts from scratch again for a
little while so that's to run the
tokenizer etc to produce a new
identifier token but then it can again
reuse stuff it can reuse the closing
parentheses and then it can rebuild a
new arguments node and a new call
expression and a new expression
statement to represent that edited part
of the code and then after that it can
again reuse stuff so it can reuse the
return statement and finally build a new
root node the program that represents
the new tree and so in that way handling
the edit it takes time that's not
proportional to the whole length of the
file
it's it's basically just proportional to
the the number of edits that you made
and the size of actual code that you've
inserted so that's all I got for you
the next things that I'm going to be
working on are adding support for more
languages in atom with tree sitter and
on github.com and to build new the next
set of features that use these syntax
trees you know I've spent all this time
basically trying to get this system
doing all the things that the old system
would do which is a lot like parsing
JavaScript inside of HTML inside of
JavaScript in
side of HTML and all those crazy things
that that basically a text made parser
can do so finally gotten to parity with
all that stuff
and now I can actually focus on building
on the new exciting things that you can
build now that we have a syntax tree in
the text editor at all times and
meanwhile the github comm data science
team is building cool [ __ ] with Haskell
that analyzes your code so you'll you'll
see stuff coming out of that at some
point both our teams are also hiring by
the way I was supposed to say that Adam
team depending on what you like to code
in yeah the Adam team and the the
semantic code team it's called so that's
it
thanks a lot for coming everyone I'm
gonna do questions on on slide oh if you
have any
[Applause]